but the committed talented people I work
with have dedicated their careers to
protecting and promoting the help of the
world's people
like them
I remain committed to building a
healthier safer and fairer future for
those people the people we all serve
on that note I wish all who celebrated a
very merry Christmas
happy Hanukkah happy New Year and joy to
all people around the world Margaret but
you
yeah
thank you very much Dr Tedros so I'll
now open the floor for questions from
the media we've got a lot of people
online I think everybody is aware that
this is our end of year presser and many
hands raised already so
I we will prioritize uh media from all
around the globe and from non-english
language
Outlets as well so I'm apologizing in
advance if you don't get your question
asked and in that Spirit the first
question goes to Antonio broto from
their Spanish newswire efe Antonio
please unmute yourself and ask your
question
dollar suitable
thank you Margaret so Mr Terrace you
made a very complete recap of this year
and now I I take two of our this
opportunity to ask you about next year
about
2023
what are you going what are the
priorities of who gonna be in in that
year and what what do you think are the
main challenges for a human Global
Health thank you
foreign
so I think Dr Ted Ross will begin
yeah thank you
so as um I think from the speech you can
imagine
some of the priorities that will roll to
2023
but
as you may know we have already
prepared our priorities not only for the
next one year but for the next five
years and our priorities for the next
year will come from the five five year
priorities that we have already
identified
and the first one is focus on health
promotion and business prevention
that will be the focus and the shift we
want to to have globally that means
instead of focusing on seek care like we
do we focus on Health Care meaning
keeping people healthy
and we will do everything to make that
happen but for that to happen we will
also focus on pushing for Universal
Health Coverage especially with a shift
to Primary Health Care as a foundation
and this is for all countries
High income middle income low income
because we have seen
how important the Primary Health Care is
how important commitment to Universal
Health Coverage is because of the covet
pandemic so that will be the second
priority but as you know to promote
Health Primary Health Care is the most
important part of the Health Care system
and that's why our focus and shift
should be at Primary Health Care and the
third will be in emergency preparedness
and and response
that will be our Focus so you have
already the three emergencies ongoing
emergencies that we need to to fight or
respond to in in the next year but while
doing that we will do everything to
prepare the world for future epidemics
so that's the third priority and the
forces
we will focus on enablers in research in
science in technology
and and other enablers to to have a
better outcome and the last one is the
continue to reform or improve who we
believe in continuous Improvement and
investing in reforming who will help us
to achieve or in helping countries to
achieve the
sdgs so these are in general the
priorities we have and the next year
this will be the guiding
priorities and
we are ready as as organization to do
our best to the success of the sdgs
because all these priorities in wh are
drawn from the sustainable development
goals and also from the experience we
had the last two to three years from the
current pandemic then with regard to
challenges of course
um you know there were there will be um
many challenges we would we would expect
but if there is one thing that will be
Central is the political commitment all
these priorities
in order to get results should be
implemented at the country level
and without a commitment at the country
level and without focus at Country level
I don't think what we are aspiring to
get will will be achieved so for sure
our Focus will be country level and we
hope countries will take health
uh as a central issue because of the
experience that we already had the whole
world had that and we will get the
commitment of course I can list a number
of
challenges we might expect but that's
the most important and if we can address
that I think the rest will be will be
addressed whether it's resources whether
it's human resources or financial
resources or or other resources can be
addressed if there is a commitment and
other challenges like Equity also could
be addressed if there is a commitment so
the central issue is around the
commitment to health and understanding
the centrality of Health there is
progress and we hope that we will
continue to be Consolidated and
and we will be able to make progress in
2023 thank you
thank you very much Dr Ted Ross and the
next question will go to the financial
times to Donato Mancini from from the
financial times Donato please unmute
yourself and ask your question
thanks for taking my question very
briefly on China
was China wrong to unlock so quickly to
ease restrictions so quickly and are you
concerned about a spillover when it
comes to neighboring countries or other
variants thank you
thank you Donato Dr Ryan will answer
your question
um
I I think that the Chinese authorities
if you look around the country it's it's
not that they've removed all um Public
Health measures uh they certainly
changed measures around
um requiring people to isolate in
designated facilities to allowing people
to isolate at home they've reduced the
requirements for daily testing to use
public transport in some areas so I
think what they've been trying to do is
to try and ease the pressure on people
provide more
manageable situations which people to
manage for people to manage their own
illnesses as such but there hasn't been
a a broad Beast if you look around the
country in certain areas lifting of
restrictions has been more than in
others but the numbers were on the rise
and we've been saying this for weeks
that the this highly infectious virus
was always going to be very hard to stop
completely with just Public Health and
Social measures and at the beginning of
this whole pandemic
we didn't have vaccines so and we had
many many Health Systems under severe
pressure we had people in ventilators we
had problems with oxygen so the
imposition of stricter Public Health and
Social measures was aimed at really
trying to to to to to dampen
transmission so as to prevent uh as much
as possible disease incidents and severe
disease so that we could protect the
health system so it could provide the
best possible care to those who were
vulnerable and suffering from severe
disease as vaccines have come on stream
we've learned that repeated vaccination
with effective vaccines the appropriate
number of doses
provides a very high level of protection
Cape May wish to speak about that
especially against severe disease and
death and most countries have really
transitioned to a mixed strategy of
maintaining some measures in terms of
reducing transmission particularly in
high risk environments many hospitals
still required to wear a mask there are
still restricted visiting many long-term
care facilities around the world
continue to protect their their
inpatients by having again restricted
access but the main focus of global
strategy has shifted to high rates of
vaccination particularly in the
vulnerable
um in the case of of of uh of China as
they've lifted some restrictions with
the the variant as infectious as as
Omicron
vaccination is is the exit strategy in
that sense from from the impact of a
wave of homicron this has been shown in
other countries in Asia like Japan uh in
Singapore in Korea we're achieving
higher rates of vaccination particularly
in the poor in the vulnerable has
resulted in the impact of Omicron waves
being much less on the health system so
that's proven that's not something
that's just speculation that is there
was clear data from the experience of
other countries the rates of vaccination
in China while on the face of it are
high there's still lag behind in terms
of overall coverage particularly when
you look at people over 60 particularly
when you look at full vaccination which
I think in the case of the available
Chinese vaccines would likely be three
doses of vaccine as a primary course not
two plus a booster
um
and I think we're talking you know
protective efficacies of hovering at 50
or less for those two dose regimes in
someone over 60. that's just not
adequate protection in in a population
as large as the population of China in
such a large population with so many
people in a vulnerable setting with that
coverage we really have to focus on
vaccination having said that China made
massive progress over the last number of
weeks in actually rolling vaccines out I
mean I think there have been a 600
percent increase or more in vaccination
rates over the last week or two weeks so
I think what we're seeing is that China
is recommitting itself to that strategy
it's distributed many different vaccines
in its Arsenal all around the country
and setting up vaccination sites it's
targeting that vaccination while
vaccinating anybody is a good idea we
would continue to emphasize the
prioritization of the vaccination of the
vulnerable particularly in getting
people to that three doors Mark and for
people many people in China who did get
to three doses of vaccine
had that vaccine a year or more ago they
would probably require a second booster
and I believe the authorities in China
have approved such a second booster and
are rolling that out so I think the
right strategic decisions are being made
the question remains whether or not
enough vaccination can be done in the
coming week two weeks that will actually
blunt the impact of the Omicron wave on
the burden on the health system it's
difficult to make that assessment as we
that was said we we don't have
complete knowledge of the impact there
are many anecdotal reports around
pressure on the health system infectious
disease then it's filling up emergency
rooms filling up and even icus filling
up on certain in certain situations and
lots of anecdotal reports of
Occupational data suggesting that many
people are off work at the moment so
there is there's pressure in the system
both in terms of infection and there's
pressure in the system in the health
system the question is quantifying that
pressure and being able to modulate the
impact of vaccination is going to have
against the pressure that's on the
health system at the moment so you know
the authorities in China have as I said
last week one in seven people on the
planet live in China and the
acceleration of vaccination the
protection of the health system during
this period is in the interest of seven
out of seven people on this planet so um
I think we we need to show solidarity We
are continuing to offer support in every
area from data management to vaccinology
to clinical management and we'll
continue to do so but after a very long
question to a very a very little long
answer to a very short question uh no I
don't I I don't think there was a switch
off and that that switch off has caused
this rise in transmission this is one of
the most the single most transmissible
variants we've ever seen as oh my grand
we have a vulnerable population and the
virus was was was going to spread in
this way around the country and it's not
fair to say that China Has Lifted all
its restrictions I think there are many
public health measures still being
applied but what they've lifted I
believe were the more astringent of
those requirements that were really
putting pressure on people in their
normal lives in their normal pursuit of
life and livelihood but in this regard
the force of infection now within the
community is very high and and really
the answer to this is vaccination and I
would also
appeal to people in China anywhere in
the world if you are sick and you think
you have covered please stay at home
don't be the next cause of the next case
so if people who are sick with
respiratory symptoms in China and you're
sick please stay home if you need health
care seek that Health Care seek the
health care early but for the vast
majority of people this is a very mild
infection this is something that passes
and by by a healthy person being able to
stay at home and manage their own case
their own disease may allow a more
vulnerable person to ease the more
easily access critical health care when
they need it thank you
let me just add a couple of things on
the vaccine side Mike has really covered
uh several of the main points and I
wanted to emphasize a couple of others
as as Mike has indicated you know China
does have a very high vaccination
coverage rate in the population the
question is really about the doses that
have been deployed in the and the
subgroups that have been vaccinated and
in particular on the course of the
elderly there are healthy 65 year olds
and then there are healthy 80 year olds
and 90 year olds and the risk of disease
across what we refer to as older adults
is not equal across all of those groups
so one of the issues is assuring that
those who are most vulnerable to having
significant disease are rapidly
vaccinated and vaccinated with a full
course of vaccines that will be
effective we know that the vaccines see
inactivated vaccines the viral vectored
vaccines and as well as the protein
vaccines are all really really effective
at protecting against severe disease and
hospitalization and death
but in particular for the inactivated
vaccines quite a bit of study has been
done on the inactivated vaccines and the
what's clear about those vaccines is
that a third dose is needed to really
get the maximum benefit of the vaccines
and that's not what I'm referring to as
a booster dose a booster dose is in
addition to that to return the
performance of a course of three doses
back to a level that they're that
they're at optimally after the receipt
of the third dose so this is one of the
points that I think is important is that
there's still a lot of effort being made
in China to rapidly scale the access to
vaccines the confidence in the community
especially in older adults because at
the outset of the pandemic there was
there was a concern about older adults
being vulnerable populations and
assuring that those older adults that
these vaccines are safe they're
effective and they are protective for
the vast majority of people from having
a severe outcome from an infection but
none of the vaccines are highly
effective at preventing infection from
taking place and certainly not highly
effective against transmission from one
person to the next so it remains
extremely important for people
especially in the most vulnerable groups
to continue to
use Public Health measures that are
going to protect them against infection
especially for those who are not yet
fully vaccinated who have not had their
booster dose who have not had their
booster dose in the past several months
which is when those booster doses are
most effective and at some point they do
decline in terms of their maximum
performance so those are some of the
points around the vaccines and the
efforts that are being made in China to
assure that everybody can have the
protection from vaccines that will
reduce the pressure on the Health Care
system and will reduce the likelihood of
deaths occurring hospitalizations
Intensive Care Unit stays that are so
devastating to families and to the
Health Care system
I'll also just mention that the use of
innovation the use of new research and
development especially for mucosal
vaccines so that we can make some
Headway some further Headway and in
China there is an inhaled vaccine which
is being deployed and my colleague Anna
Maria may want to say a little bit more
about mucosal vaccines because that
really is the Innovation that's needed
so that we have products that are more
effective than the current products are
on that more mild end of the disease
Spectrum the infection end of the
disease Spectrum the transmission end of
the disease Spectrum so that's that's
something that we need to look forward
to in 2023 is greater uh
investment certainly and and uh a
greater set of results coming out about
those Investments that have already been
made thank you
thank you very much Dr O'Brien and Dr
Ryan for those really comprehensive
answers the next question goes to come
and pound from Politico uh common unmute
yourself and ask a question
thank you so much Margaret um just
following up on China and the
vaccination
um much has been done much has been made
about why China has an approved
non-chinese developed vaccines and you
know things like the MRNA vaccines and I
was wondering if the who has had any
dialogue with the Chinese authorities
about this about sort of like allowing a
greater you know range of vaccines on
the market
um so I don't know people could
eventually pick and choose to get
vaccinated if they have doubts about you
know a certain vaccine has there been
any conversation about that have you
heard anything on it from the Chinese
authorities thank you
Dr Ryan will answer that question
although we're not involved we believe
there are discussions going on between
the Chinese authorities and some at
least one of the MRNA manufacturers
around registration of their vaccines
and also around production within China
itself but we're not privy to those
discussions we would encourage that
obviously and maybe Richard who your
group works very much on this we would
certainly encourage that kind of work
both to import vaccines but also to find
Arrangements where vaccines can be
produced in as many places as possible
to the proper standards so uh certainly
yes this will be a good idea but I do
believe the Chinese authorities are are
pursuing this and it will be better to
ask them I suppose and the MRNA
manufacturers directly which area
if you can add something on on that
thank you Mike we had a meeting with the
Chinese authorities and the Chinese
science community and manufacturers a
couple of months ago and we are aware of
an extensive pipeline of different
platforms that are being developed by
the science community and the
manufacturers in China
why China doesn't approve vaccines from
outside of why they are not submitted
it's a question of course between the
manufacturers and China just to remember
that if any of the parties would be
willing to do it could have used already
the UL system from who as did 175
countries over more than 5 000 National
regulatory approvals with the 16 e-wells
that we approved
thank you very much for those uh answers
Dr Ryan and Dr Gaspar
the next question goes to Aaron dondrea
from Global News in Canada Aaron plays
on mute yourself and asks a question
hi there
um my question is for for Dr Ted Johnson
and really the the panel in general but
here in Canada the auditor general
released a recent report that found the
federal government
bought more covid-19 vaccines than
needed for the Canadian population and
one billion worth of those coveted
vaccines are likely to expire soon now
the who has been adamant on
International vaccine Equity throughout
the pandemic
so what does it make of the fact that
one of the wealthiest governments in the
world
has one billion worth of covid-19
vaccines that are about to expire thank
you
Dr O'Brien will answer that question
the issue of vaccine Equity is uh such a
critical issue and an issue that Dr
Tedros and who have been certainly
speaking out about throughout the course
of the pandemic as as we're all aware uh
countries at the beginning of the
pandemic nobody knew which vaccines were
going to work uh nobody knew which of
the vaccines among them how many of them
were going to work how many of them
would actually reach authorization and
Canada as has been reported publicly as
well as many countries entered into
contracts at risk not knowing whether
one of those contracts would end up you
know resulting in actual Deployable
vaccine or whether many of those
contracts would end up with Deployable
vaccine
um what is uh what has been really
important is to
um really focus on the availability of
supply for all countries in the world at
the earliest possible time I'll just
remind people that it was 39 days
between when the first dose of vaccine
was deployed in a high income country
and when a dose was deployed in a low
middle income country now that's um what
would be ideal would be zero days
difference between those two factors but
it there has been the the role of Kovacs
in deploying vaccines to countries
around the world of all income strata
but particularly providing over 80
percent of the doses to low-income
countries has been really essential
in the course of a an emergency in the
course of a pandemic in the course of a
situation where there is the need for
vaccine for all people who need vaccine
any one place in the world that has
excess vaccine that should be deployed
to other parts of the world and many
countries have been very generous in
their donations of excess vaccines
through the Kovacs facility and through
bilateral donations to assure the
deployment of those doses to countries
that otherwise could use those doses in
a timely fashion and we've been very
explicit about the need for those doses
to be deployed in a timeline where
countries can use them so that expiry
dates are not imminent at the point in
time when doses have have arrived in
countries and many countries have heeded
that call and a substantial number of
the doses out of the Kovacs Facility
have been on the basis of donations of
countries that have other wise paid for
their vaccines for for their domestic
use what we need to really focus on is
not that there were countries that
really procured excess vaccine because
in the setting of a pandemic in fact
anything that you do to assure that
there is enough product to vaccinate
everybody around the world those are not
wasted resources at all we accept from
in many other sectors that we have a
reserve that is present that we have
Commodities in excess of what we need in
assurance that we don't end up in a
supply constrained environment so I
think it's not so much about whether or
not the world has more doses of covid
vaccine than it needs in fact that's
exactly the position that we would want
to be in to assure that there are doses
everywhere to be used in every setting
where doses are needed the real issue is
on the equity side and on the
availability of those services for every
country in the world for every need that
they have we're in a situation now where
Supply is ample that Supply is available
for all countries for the demand that
they have and we are going into 2023
especially for the Kovacs facility where
we are looking at to certainly be able
to provide all all supply for the demand
that has been expressed by countries and
for them to reach the Ambitions that
they have so I think what we're really
looking at is in a future situation that
we have in the early part when Supply is
constrained that there is a more fair
system
wherein supply of vaccine is deployed
according to need and is deployed in an
equitable way but excess doses at the
global level at the country level is
really a decision on the basis on a
country-by-country basis
um but I think we want to really
emphasize that when you're in a
situation of emergency what we do want
is we want there to be sufficient to
supply to meet every need that is that
is possible
um and and I think that's where we
certainly are and have been through most
of uh 2022 and in the latter half of
2021. thank you
thank you very much Dr O'Brien we'll now
go to India to
um
media India Puja please on mute yourself
and ask a question
well thank you for taking my question my
question is again on China what are the
reasons that you see behind the current
Surge and do you see us still over to
other neighboring countries like India
thank you
that wasn't completely clear now you
mentioned that
um what do we think are the reasons for
the search in in China and are we
concerned about spillover to other
countries is that what you said exactly
yes we'll go to Maria van kirkov who's
been following this very closely and is
joining us online
hi Margaret yes just confirming you can
hear me okay
um thanks very much for the questions so
I think a lot of this was was covered in
in the answer previously from Mike
there's a lot of reasons for um this
surge that we're seeing in China but
also elsewhere so um as you know some of
the restrictions around the world a lot
of the restrictions around the world
have been eased and Omicron the latest
variants of concern is the most
transmissible variant we have seen so
far including all the sub-variants that
are in circulation more than 500 of them
and so we will continue to see surges of
infection around the world
um the question is the impact and we
have seen a decline in the impact of
covid-19 over the last year for sure
because we have population level
immunity that is increasing now clearly
what we need to do in all countries
including in China to increase
vaccination coverage in those who are
most at risk people who are over the age
of 60 people who are immunocompromised
with underlying conditions and our front
line workers and that includes receive
leaving the full number of doses that
are required for them and until we see
that we will still see significant
numbers of hospitalizations ICU
Admissions and deaths in the last week
alone we had more than 10 000 deaths
reported two who globally and over the
last month more than forty thousand so
we're still in this very much around the
world the big concern obviously that we
have with China as the as the DG has
outlined is the increasing reports of
severe disease what we need to ensure is
not only our is vaccination coverage
increasing but that we optimize and that
the country optimizes clinical care for
those who need it
um staying home if you if you can be
cared for at home making sure that you
seek medical attention if necessary and
that the Health Care Systems can have
that clinical care pathway outlined very
clearly to deal with those who need the
care the most making best use of those
beds making best use of antivirals that
need to be accessible at sub-national
levels and it's never too late to
vaccinate I think that's one of the key
also key messages we want to see that's
out there with regards to variants one
of the other earlier questions was
around variance and we are tracking
variants in China as well as elsewhere
by far the dominant sublingenas of
Omicron that are circulating are the
ba.5 sub lineages this is true in China
as well we see the bq1 the bf7 which are
sublimities of b8.5 but China also has
ba.2.75 and they also have detect
detected xbb so it's really critical
that we are continuing to monitor the
known variants as well as be able to
detect new ones so that strategies if
necessary can be adjusted one of the
critical things we have seen with
Omicron is that each of these
sublineages have a growth Advantage
they're highly transmissible each of
these have some level of immune escape
and we do see a similar level of
severity of Omicron sub lineages across
all of the Omicron Sublime news so we
haven't seen an increase in severity or
a decent decrease in severity for that
matter and remember Omicron can cause
the full spectrum of disease everything
from asymptomatic infection all the way
to death but the good news is that our
tools are still working so again we need
to optimize the response in all
countries including in China make sure
that Health Care Systems do not get
overwhelmed we're concerned of what we
are seeing in terms of this increase in
severity and we are here to support
um
the our colleagues in China to optimize
that care and make sure that that
vaccination coverage reaches the highest
level in the critical groups thanks
thank you so much Dr Van kirkoff uh the
next question goes to uh Adam Taylor
from The Washington Post Adam please
unmute yourself and ask your question
hi there um thanks for having me
um I was wondering you mentioned the
need for more data from China earlier
how much confidence does the who have in
the data that is coming out of China and
is there any reason to believe that
Beijing is misrepresenting the scale of
the outbreak
I Can Begin no I I do think that we've
seen this in surges in other countries
it can always take time generally
hospital and we found this across the
world epidemiologic data that's reported
on testing and the labs reporting and
clinicians reporting within surveillance
systems can and if they're well
organized happens quickly very often
Hospital data is harder to get it
because very often Hospital data is
generated on discharge it's usually
associated associated with insurance or
payments so you wait till the patient is
discharged and then you can have their
ICD diagnosis of what they had and the
bill goes to the patient or the
insurance company so very often
hospitals surveillance is more about who
pays what to whom so therefore the data
is always far behind
secondly you don't in most hospitals
around the world have Dynamic
surveillance of who's in the emergency
room versus who's being admitted versus
who's getting oxygen or supportive care
versus who's going into the ICU this is
not generally collected in real time in
hospitals many countries have had to
learn how to do that during the pandemic
and many countries have become quite
skilled at finding alternative means to
gather that data sometimes they gather
it straight from the databases in the
hospital sometimes they do Hospital
surveys they sometimes just call around
and say how many people are in your ICU
so we've all had to adapt these aren't
required reporting to who we do ask for
these data if they're available but in
many situations we reach out and look at
websites around the world and we try to
pull that data together ourselves in the
case currently in China
what's being reported uh is relatively
known numbers of cases in hospital or
relatively no number of cases in icus
while ionic globally there are reports
that those icus are filling up now it
could be again that the reported data is
behind the reality in in a fast-moving
wave you might have reported three days
ago that your hospital is okay
this morning it may not be okay because
the wave has come and all of a sudden
you were very high force of infection so
I wouldn't like to say that the China
are actively not telling us what's going
on I think they're behind the curve in
what's actually happening as everyone is
in a situation like this and we need to
get better ways of getting that data
quickly so we can monitor together the
situation because it's it's in the
interest of the Chinese Health System to
know where the pressure is in the system
at any one time that allows you to move
resources move PPE move health workers
move oxygen move patients sometimes you
need that Dynamic data to manage the
emergency it's one of the great lessons
I think we've learned in covert that
impact management during a pandemic
we're very good at detection and doing
the Epi surveillance we're not so good
around the world at dynamically managing
the health system stress during a
pandemic and in order to manage that
stress and be agile you need data you
need to be able to react to what's
actually happening not what you think is
happening not to what someone else
things is happening not to what the
media thinks is happening but to what's
actually happening and and I do think
many countries struggle with that I
think China's struggling with getting
that data in real time and we would
certainly be very grateful if we can
work and assist China in improving the
ways they collect data around those
critical factors hospitalization
the need for oxygen-based therapy
admission to ICU and death one
um other issue is how you define death
associated with covert I believe the
definition in China is quite narrow it's
quite focused on respiratory failure
people who die of cold would die from
many different systems failures given
the severity of the infection so
limiting a diagnosis of death from
covert to someone with a covert positive
test and respiratory failure will very
much underestimate the true death toll
associated with covert so again we would
we don't want the definitions to get in
the way of actually getting the right
data so um with that we will continue to
work with our colleagues at their who
country office in China who work on a
daily basis with their kind of at the
National Health commission the Ministry
of Health at the China CDC and we will
do our best to ensure that they can like
the rest of the world learn lessons and
how best to collect Dynamic data on
health impact during events like this
thank you Dr Ryan and Dr Van kirkov has
got some points to make about data and
collection as well over to you Maria
yeah just very thank you just very
briefly to add on that we at who compile
multiple sources of data so as Mike
pointed out there's a lot of different
information that can come from a country
and in different time points and as he
said we will continue to work through
our country office with our country
office with our region and with our
technical partners and Country but I
just wanted to add that we also have a
lot of clinical networks and IPC
networks our tag ve where we are working
with Scientists in China to gather
information to learn from information
about the circulating variants about the
impact on the Health Care System about
patient care Etc so there are multiple
sources of information that are coming
in but I want to go back to one point is
we know a lot about Omicron right now we
don't know everything but we know enough
to be able to plan to be able to use
available information and to look at
different types of scenarios as we go
for forward let's look about what we
know you know Omicron is the most
transmissible variant we have seen so we
expect there to be increasing case
numbers so whether or not these are
actually able to be detected in the
current situation and reported to us we
know that case numbers are increasing we
do know that on average the infection
with Omicron is less severe compared to
Delta and we do know that vaccines
prevent people from developing severe
disease and debt these are things that
can be used to help maintain and adjust
the Healthcare systems that are in
country we also know that there are
co-circulation of other pathogens we
have influenza that is in circulation we
have RSV that is in circulation so the
more case numbers that are out there for
covid or for other respiratory diseases
will add pressure to health systems that
are fragile this is true in China but it
is also true elsewhere so I think we
have to be really careful right now that
we are in while we are in a much better
situation globally in dealing with 19
the situation is fragile because our
Health Care Systems are fragile and our
ability to adjust the elasticity in the
system around the world is really not
there so we have to be prepared and
that's what we're doing with our member
states how do we write sizes response
for surveillance to be able to track
this virus as well as other respiratory
diseases like influenza how do we
support the Health Care Systems to scale
up and scale Down based on the needs how
do we get good information out to
individuals so that they know what to do
we take for for granted that we think
everyone knows what is needed to be done
for covid because we say it every day
but perhaps that message isn't actually
reaching the populations so there's a
lot of information that can be gathered
we will continue to work to make sure
that we have the right information
particularly on burden hospitalizations
ICU capacity how many people are
requiring oxygen and looking at that by
age looking at that by vaccination dose
is really critical for us to make these
assessments but again as as Mike has
said as DG said we stand ready to
continue to support China to continue to
support all countries in adjusting their
response to reduce that burden and we
don't you know the scenarios that we
look at the predictions the pr the
models that are out there are
predictions they aren't a certainty
there's a lot that it was is within our
hands in the hands of government to
reduce that impact and that's what we
are critically focused on right now
thank you very much Dr Van kerkov and Dr
Ryan uh we're coming up to the hour but
I think we can squeeze one to two more
questions in
um yes okay so we'll go to pretty
patnaik from Geneva health files pretty
unmute yourself and ask a question
good afternoon
um thanks for taking my question
um so so this week uh WTO members failed
to reach an agreement to
um you know uh easing IP rules for
covid-19 tests and treatments so my
question is are we as unprepared as
before as far as tests and treatments
are concerned
um there has been an overwhelming
emphasis on vaccination and even today
we are talking about vaccination but in
the context of rising cases uh in China
um are we as unprepared as far as access
to treatments and Diagnostics are
concerned and what is the meaning of
this failure to reach a decision what
kind of consequences do you think it
will have immediately thanks
is that related to
Kovacs or Gabby border
Tristan treat okay we'll have to but if
I could make a general kind of pretty
thanks for raising the issue first of
all because uh it's important that these
issues are raised because as we look to
a situation on one side of the world we
then make some assumptions that we're
all fine on this side or somewhere else
and and it's not exactly true certainly
our testing has dropped significantly
um in in all around the world and this
is leaving us blind so and and we do
need to keep diagnostics at the center
and not only diagnostics from the
perspective of surveillance but
diagnostics from the perspective of
early diagnosis particularly in
vulnerable people who may have an
infection and may their vaccines may not
work perfectly and getting those people
onto treatment so Diagnostics are
intimately associated with the intention
to treat the patient for that disease
it's important because if you've got a
respiratory disease right now and you're
an old vulnerable person you're probably
50 50 likely to have covered or maybe
flu and the antivirals are totally
different so there are consequences to
not having the right diagnosis
especially if you're a highly vulnerable
person so integrating Diagnostics and
when I said this last week what we need
to do is start moving in countries that
have good control over the virus right
now high levels of vaccination
integrating Diagnostics into Primary
Health Care and Family Health Care
integrating the antivirals into that
care pathway having a strong referral
pathway into a hospital-based system
that can provide high levels of
supportive Care oxygen and intensive
care if needed but the Baseline for all
of that is high levels of vaccination in
the population at Large has every
country got that in place right now in
the world absolutely not I think
countries have done a good job in
general around vaccination those who had
access to the vaccine and and thanks to
go backs for for making that a vaccine
available to billions of people who
wouldn't otherwise have got it
um but the reality is that with
Diagnostics and with Therapeutics and
with access to healthcare not just
Therapeutics with basic Access to Health
Care in terms of if you get very sick do
you have access access to oxygen we
haven't fixed the oxygen problem we
haven't fixed the ICU problem we haven't
fixed the the the out-of-pocket expenses
that people suffer when they get very
very sick and I mean one one
one severe illness and one family member
in many families in this world will
impoverish that family for Generations
that's the reality that people face and
they face desperate decisions and if I
save my father if I save my mother then
my kids are not going to go to school
that is not a fantasy choice that
happens every single day of the week so
there are weaknesses in our health care
act there is no one called weaknesses
there is gross Injustice in the way
people Access Health Care and the ways
in which they can and that has as much
impact on your outcome and covert as any
antiviral and I do think there are huge
weaknesses still left in our system we
have health workers who are tired the
incidence of PTSD and social anxiety
syndromes in health workers is very high
many health workers are leaving
field health workers have seen their
incomes fall behind as they worked hard
at the front line
and the economic crisis hit they were
left behind and they're now looking at
the Stark future of less pay for more
work more stress for Less recognition
and many are choosing to leave the field
so no I don't think we're in great tedra
said we're in better situation than we
were no question but are we ready to
take the hit of another wave of a new
variant that might emerge
I don't think so and that's why
vaccination is so Central it really is
the get out of jail card we need it and
remains to be so but unless it's no good
unless we use it really and truly it
doesn't do any good it's not about
vaccines it's about vaccination you keep
saying that sir okay so I'll say the
last words it's not about vaccines it's
about vaccination
I think on that note we'll wrap up I
think that's a really important message
for 2023.
um and I thank you all I apologize to
those of you who didn't get your
question asked you can send it to Media
inquiries and we'll do our best to get
you answers as quickly as possible and
with that and we'll also send of course
a transcript and the the audio and
official files from this presser out
this evening and with that I'll hand
over to Dr Tedros for his final remarks
thank you thank you margarita
so thank you to the Press members of the
press for joining us
and merry Christmas happy happy New Year
and I include Hanukkah
and see you next time next year thank
you